Jake:就像昨天的那个一样可以吗
Jake: Like yesterday's, is that okay?
Lucia: 啊procred有录屏的
Lucia: Ah, Procreate has screen recording.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 虽然我没有带iPad
Lucia: Although I didn't bring my iPad.
Lucia: 所以没有办法用procreate了
Lucia: So I can't use Procreate.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:没关系剧组报销一台
Jake: It's okay, the crew will reimburse for one.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:假的
Jake: Fake.
Lucia: 那我现在立刻就下单
Lucia: Then I'll place an order right now.
Lucia: 这个软件我都买了
Lucia: I already bought this software.
Lucia: 我可以先下到新的那个上面
Lucia: I can download it to the new one first.
Alice:这个软件可以买一下吗
Alice: Can you buy this software?
Jake:没有没钱
Jake: No, no money.
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Lucia: 9哎现在98了
Lucia: Oh, it's 98 now.
Lucia: 68吗不是
Lucia: Wasn't it 68? No.
Lucia: 88好像 98不记得了
Lucia: I think it was 88 or 98, can't remember.
Lucia: 我买的时候对是个8结尾的数字
Lucia: When I bought it, the number ended in 8.
Lucia: 但是具体多少我忘了
Lucia: But I forgot the exact amount.
Lucia: 不是一是个8结尾的数字是干啥的
Lucia: Was it... it ended in 8. What's it for?
Jake:就是那个
Jake: It's that one.
Lucia: 嗯可以画画哦
Lucia: Oh, you can draw with it.
Lucia: 其实也可以做动画哦
Lucia: Actually, you can make animations too.
Lucia: 但是我水平太差了做不了动画
Lucia: But I'm not good enough to make animations.
Lucia: 哈哈这位妹子应该可以
Lucia: Haha, this girl should be able to.
Lucia: 我她选那个
Lucia: Should I call you by your Chinese name?
Lucia: 我应该叫你中文还是叫好
Lucia: Or is it okay if I call you...
Jake:应该叫你什么
Jake: What should I call you?
Jake:我也没整明白
Jake: I'm not sure either.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Lucia: 好的薇薇应该可以
Lucia: Okay, Tasha should be fine.
Jake:薇薇是吗
Jake: Tasha, right?
Jake:好嘞微微
Jake: Okay, Tasha.
Jake:可以问问管家
Jake: You can ask the butler.
Jake:就是这边的人
Jake: The people here.
Jake:能不能帮你把
Jake: If they can help you...
Lucia: 哈哈哈试图偷盗一些灵感
Lucia: Hahaha, trying to steal some inspiration.
Jake:帮你帮你
Jake: Help you, help you.
Jake:把床给卸了
Jake: Take apart the bed.
Jake:把这个床给挪开
Jake: Move this bed aside.
Jake:知道能不能
Jake: You know, if they can...
Alice:哈哈哈偷
Alice: Hahaha, steal...
Alice:做作业中
Alice: Doing homework
Alice:我们俩房间不太一样抄不了
Alice: Our rooms are different, can't copy
Jake:一般抄作业
Jake: Usually, copying homework
Jake:是别人做完的抄吧
Jake: means copying someone else's finished work, right?
Lucia: 这个从过程就开始抄
Lucia: This one starts copying from the process
Lucia: 就万一被老师问到
Lucia: Just in case the teacher asks
Lucia: 你就跟他说出来你是怎么做的
Lucia: you can explain how you did it
Lucia: 哈哈也是
Lucia: Haha, true
Jake:也是
Jake: True
Jake:对我们先下载那个软件
Jake: Yes, let's download that software first
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe
Jake:免户型一起抄是吧
Jake: Copying the layout, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈户型抄不了
Lucia: Hahaha, can't copy the layout
Katrina: 行抄不了
Katrina: Yeah, can't copy
Alice:然后直接直接从淘宝把图片下载下来
Alice: Then just download the images from Taobao directly
Alice:然后贴上去
Alice: and paste them
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Jake:我这房间我是装潢完了
Jake: I've finished decorating my room
Jake:我是
Jake: I am
Alice:就你赛博风
Alice: You're cyber style
Lucia: 哈哈你就赛博朋克风
Lucia: Haha, you're cyberpunk style
Jake:赛博朋克风
Jake: Cyberpunk style
Jake:确实装饰了我一晚上哈哈
Jake: It really took me a whole night to decorate, haha